are you in need of some greenery at your
home but you're worried because you've
killed every single plant you've ever
touched
well there may be hope business insider
reports
the sill which is a company that
delivers
the plants right to you and they will
tell you
how to take care of them detailed info
on
what each plant needs in terms of
brightness sun exposure humidity water
etc
so your plant massacres can finally end
check them out if you have a urine to
fern
i have to say i really love this because
i i do really love plants and i need a
little guidance i don't have the
greenest of thumbs
so i'm very excited and i'm going to
check this sill program out too
but i'd like to talk about something
that really bugs me
i have to talk about it like i want to
play it cool but sometimes things just
really
ruffle my feathers
all right the built-in bra pads to a
swimsuit
these ruffle my feathers you know the
ones they're those two little foam
pieces that
ride around in a strange pocket that
you're supposed to sport
on your chest and i just wonder what
insane person
thought you know what i have an idea i
am going to decide
what your chest looks like and how it
functions
this really ruffles my feathers because
they're these tiny foam pancakes
and yeah this is not looking so good it
was so much cuter in rehearsal
wow okay this is yeah okay you try
wearing a white bathing suit over your
clothes all right
all i know is that if you think this is
irritating how about that your decisions
have been made for you
with these boobs what's up with that and
then you can like
go in there and take them out but if you
wash it then they
roll up like a caterpillar that never
retakes its shape anyway i'm just saying
the bikini two why why have you decided
what my things are why am i trapped in
your world
it just it ruffles my feathers
thank you thank you chicken i really do
appreciate it
listen i just want to tell the bathing
suit companies
that i'm already dealing with my own
body images
and trying to be comfortable in my skin
but when i
feel like it's already been like
geometrically decided for me in a way
that doesn't really
work i just want to say you're ruffling
my feathers
and finally
thank you
and finally you may have seen this very
viral photo in your feed
because it's the inspirational first
all-female fighter crew
in 57 years of the palm beach gardens
fire department
yes this is just so
awesome we celebrate you here at the
show and guess what
they're here so please welcome
representing a combined
80 years of fire experience christina
kelsey
julie sandy and captain monica
hello we're so excited
i am so honored that you would come and
visit us on this show because
we are so wild for you and
julie how did this come about
um it just it actually happened
organically we've had a lot of staffing
changes due to people being promoted or
being retired
and christina and i were on overtime
that day so it just
happened we were all in the same house
together um and we decided to since it
was such a special day take a picture
um not only to commemorate all of us
being together
but to honor our brother uh firefighter
brian who's battling cancer
um and we had his shirts on the
firefighter to the rescue shirts so
we just wanted to show him that we loved
him and and it just kind of went wild
yeah oh and christina this was the same
day
that rbg passed is that correct or
around that time
oh it was the same day we found out the
next day getting off shift that
what occurred and wow i mean number one
that added more to the story for us
you know because of that um because we
felt like we were a representation of
what she fought so hard for
you know equality for all and
if you could ever be a better
representation i certainly don't know
how and sandy
did this day because of everything and
brian and rbg and this
phenomenal first in so long did it feel
different that day
it felt a little different the
communication was impeccable we had
definitely we were all good at talking
to each other
i love that because you know women
also can like be over sharers and over
talkers so it's awesome if it's like
it's succinct we got it done we were in
perfect rhythm
we talk about being like a symphony here
and we're all
have instruments and those instruments
are sometimes in sync and
sometimes they're playing jazz and it's
just amazing to hear
that like everything was just in such
perfect rhythm that day
monica as captain did it feel like that
for you
uh well it started for me the night
before i knew that this was going to
definitely draw a lot of attention so my
number one priority was to
safely lead the crew through the shift
but
i've worked with all of them before at
one time or another and honestly these
ladies made it very easy
it was a wonderful shift well you were
absolutely right
uh everyone did freak out the whole
internet went wild
and like kelsey did you have friends
respond to this
because captain monica is so right it's
like she knew that this was going to be
really
epic and it was yeah everyone responded
i mean
all of our co-workers they knew the
schedule
before the day also so they were really
excited
um but after the photo posted people
all over the country i didn't even know
messaged family i didn't even know that
it was on the news we're telling us
um it was really cool to see the
response that we got from everyone yeah
i love that and christina what would you
say to any other women out there who see
this
and want to follow in your footsteps and
become firefighters
i would say to keep charging ahead to
follow your dreams and do what you love
follow your heart and don't let anyone
talk you out of it just go forward
oh my gosh you guys are just
julie christina sandy kelsey and captain
monica
it is such an honor to honor you
thank you
thank you
i hope one day i can never be anything
like you you are the most
inspiring women i'm serious it is an
inspiration to talk to you and to
be a part of this story for this moment
thank you
i will carry it in my heart forever as
we all will be celebrating you
thank you ladies for coming on the show
you